Air strikes in Syria resume on the rebel-held eastern section of Aleppo,...
...destroying much of the city.
US Secretary of State John Kerry calls for another ceasefire.
In India, the government orders 36 Rafale fighter jets from France for 8.8 billion dollars...
...to counter the growing Chinese threat.
In Gaza, members of Hamas gather to protest the US designation of a Hamas leader...
...as a "global terrorist," as well as Israel's detention of Hamas prisoners.
In Egypt, authorities and fishermen continue to search the sea...
...for bodies from a capsized migrant boat, whose official death toll reaches 145.
And finally from Romania, 2,000 people protest over the Senate's refusal...
...to lift immunity from a former interior minister,...
...who was being prosecuted for "involuntary homicide."